hello everyone and welcome back to round
six uh of the uh matches.com grand swiss
currently being played in riga uh latvia
it's alexis shore versus alireza
ferrugia after that uh 14 move
brilliancy miniature that jobaba played
that we have uh the the well the most
expected and the most awaited uh match
up uh shiro versus ferugia and it's uh
quite quite an interesting game before
we check out the game we even have a
photo of this um of this clash so there
you have it uh the
um first move for white for sure being
made by maris krakow's the president of
the latvian chess federation uh if you
guys want to enjoy this for a few
seconds that's totally cool uh usually i
i spot at least something wrong with
every photo but here i i can't seem to
figure out anything if you guys see
anything you know weird about this photo
uh do share so we can all enjoy this
because i mean there's always something
weird in in a photo
that being said uh let's check out the
game so shiro with the white pieces
opens with e4 and i was already
surprised by uh first choice of the
first movie as he played c5 against
everyone so uh he he wants to fight he
goes for the sicilian and i thought uh
you know shiro being the attacking
genius that he is uh firujo would
welcome the opportunity to play the
sicilian against him but he goes for c6
he goes for the karo khan defense uh why
this is so probably to
out prepare him as shiro was of course
expecting a furusa to go for the
sicilian but also maybe uh i don't know
maybe he
uh things that uh i don't think ferruja
would think that he would out out
maneuver him in some crazy lines but uh
you know this is more of a uh
uh preparation thing i believe uh but
okay uh c6 the karo khan defense we have
d for d5 and now e5 going for the
sharpest advanced variation of the car
con we have bishop to f5 before closing
the setup with e6 and now it's uh too
early to go for the bayonet attack and
this has been very well analyzed for
black so you don't really have all that
much to worry about but shiro goes for
h4 and what better move to play in the
regal latvia than the tal variation of
the advanced karo khan that is the h4
move and now g4 could be a problem
because now if bishop g6 h5
is a problem so here we have h5 by black
now
this will allow you to uh later on uh
maybe put this knight on f5 this uh pawn
on h5 will prevent uh y from pushing g4
at any point so your knight will be
nicely placed on f5 since white already
advanced his pawn all the way to e5
you're not going to be able to kick it
away so it makes sense uh bishop to d3
attacking this uh only developed piece
and now bishop captures queen captures
and queen to a5 with check and now you
could block this with the knight to d2
you could play bishop to d you could
play pawn to c3 if you play queen to d2
uh the bishop to d2 is what's usually
played but here we have knights to d2 uh
shoot of uh we will play c3 at some
point maybe then play knight to b3 kick
away the queen then maybe bring the
knight to c5 uh so i'm trying to take
advantage of this uh weird position of
the black queen we have e6 and now
knight to f3 and here uh you like we
said we want to bring this knight to f5
so we could play knight e7 and then to
f5 but ferruccio goes knight to h6
followed by knight to f5 uh there's
probably some difference uh i don't know
what it is but uh uh probably it's uh
it's a very subtle thing that you know
someone who is a very well versed in
this opening uh will know uh but okay we
have castles and now knight to f5 the
knight lands on a f5 right away we have
knights to be three now attacking the
queen and the queen to a6 offering a
queen trade
you know it's not that [ __ ] of uh you
know doesn't want the queen's uh traded
over the board even though he probably
does enjoy positions with queens on the
board but this would just be uh you know
giving black free development so he just
brings the queen back queen to d1 and
now bishop to e7 uh now attacking this
h4 pawn twice but now comes bishop to g5
we have bishop captures and g5 and now
the position has been reached before and
uh h captures on g5 exclusively was
played here but here uh shiro throws in
a nice in between move a nice fishing
suit and he plays knight to c5 attacking
the black queen on a6 and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game asking furuja what do you do with
your queen now so uh obviously we should
uh
the defend the be a seven pawn but uh
it's very hard to imagine you playing
something that doesn't defend it maybe
like queen to c4 but even this uh you
know it isn't out of the question but
okay he goes queen to b6 now you still
have pressure uh on this pawn and also
you are attacking the b2 pawn so here
knight captures and g5 and now uh what
do you play here well it's a very very
tricky if you go for something like
queen captures on b2 probably what shiro
was hoping for then this would be pretty
much a dream position for him you get to
sacrifice some material on e6f captures
knight captures and here black is just
uh really
uh
just terrible i mean knight to c7 checks
being threatened uh whatever you play uh
let's say you play queen to b6 that
prevented this we can even play rook to
b1 and now you you really don't have a
good move queen to d3 followed by queen
to f5 can always be played now let's say
after knight moves after the queen moves
rook captures on b7 and black is
completely busted uh this would not end
well for black
so instead after night the knight
captures on g5 we have knight to a6 you
could also just capture on h4 this is
perfectly fine but firoja prefers
development he plays knight to a6 now we
have knight captures on a6 queen
captures on a6 not even b captures to
keep uh attacking this pawn because the
queen is very well placed here on b6
attacking this there's uh you know uh
more pressure on the d4 pawn the h4 pawn
that's not an h4nd h that's not the h4
pawn is being attacked uh and it would
make sense to keep the queen here but
ferrujo has a different idea he plays
queen captures on a6 and now uh he says
all right if you want to play something
like g3 you can defend this pawn but
that's only going to weaken your king's
position so here we instead we have c3
uh sorry about that uh and now only now
ferruja captures the h4 pawn but now
shiro will try to use the h file for
himself i know that sounds pretty crazy
but that's how shiro rolls so here g5
knight to f5 and now king the g2 now
with some ideas of rook to h1 rook
captures an h5 so queen to b6 alireza
now wants to
bring the queen back uh with some queen
to d8 queen to a7 maneuvers but for a
moment also pressuring b2 so b4 by
sheriff queen to d8 and now queen to d2
defending this knight on g5 and only now
queen to e7 preparing to castle queen
side uh rook eight to b1 saying all
right you castle queenside then b5 is
coming and then i'm the one who's
attacking so furuja still waits with
with the castling he plays rook to h6
now he wants to play rook to g6 put
pressure on the knight and if the knight
moves maybe even h4 can be played and
then white king could be in trouble so
rook to h1 now saying okay if you play
rook to g6 now i'm just going to capture
here so it doesn't really make sense uh
so here finally firuja castle's queen
side and uh of course you know that
black is going to start an attack on the
king side so you want to uh beat him to
it and attack on the queen side so b5
here by shiro uh and you do not want to
allow c captures on
b characters on c6 that would be uh
simply giving white too much so c
captures on b5 is the absolute best idea
here rook captures on b5 ended now we
have h4
uh starting his own attack on the kings
side because
we have castles of on opposite sides of
the board and usually the player who
starts attacking first will win the
attack so g4 we have to stop the attack
somehow to continue our attack maybe we
play some like rook h to b1 put pressure
on b7 if b6 maybe we can even play a4 a5
maybe we can play c for bust open the
position this way
and here alireza finds a very
interesting move and that is uh h3 with
check
rook the g6 is also possible
but then f4 defends it and you know who
knows what's happening there so instead
he goes for h3 with check uh saying that
okay if you capture now which did not
happen in the game but i will just show
it quickly for example captures captures
now we're going to play knight to h for
with check and if king g3 rook to h8 and
it's a really really
weird position where white probably has
to play queen to g5 but uh black would
of course keep the queens on the board
captures captures and we get this
position where black is definitely
better so instead should have played
king to f1 he wants the like we said
close the attack on the king side and
start the attack on the queen side and
now rook the g6 attacking the knight
here so g captures on f5 rook captures
on g5 and now f captures an e6 so
destroying uh that pawn chain a little
bit f captures on e6 and only now rook
captures on h3 and now
how can alireza continue the attack here
he starts with rook to f5 it makes sense
we want to play rook uh d to f8 and then
put more pressure on the f2 pawn
and uh of course shiro needs to
hurry up with the attack of his own so
c4 he wants to capture here get the
other rook into the attack so d captures
on c4 this is best for the moment at
least the uh c file is closed and now
queen to c3 getting uh ready to capture
here so rook d the f8 now threatening
rook captures on f2 and now we have
queen captures on c4 with check king to
b8 and now rook back to b2 guarding that
f2 pawn and now queen to f7 firuja
triples on the f file now again
threatening rook captures on f2 and now
queen back to e2
so shiro had to bring uh some of his
pieces back from the attack and now he's
ready to bring this rook into the attack
and hopefully open up the position with
maybe pushing of the a pawn but that's
that's a lot of moves so here queen to
c7 a really tricky move by alireza now
preparing queen to c1 check for example
if you play something like rook h to b3
now it looks very scary but we throw in
this check and this is now a problem uh
for example queen to e1
if you go here then we just start with
rook g5 check here and then uh rook h8
will be game over so here uh let's say
queen to e1 we're going to play queen to
c4 with check and now after queen to e2
again if you go up the board then the
rooks are just ending the game so queen
to e2 but now let's say rook captures an
f2 and that's it the queen is pinned of
course the queen cannot capture and
after you move this let's say captures
captures and queen c1 checkmate so uh
this is something uh
that that will be possible if this is
allowed so here instead queen to c2
blocking this check and now uh queen
back to d7 uh here the real question is
do you want to give up two rooks for a
queen uh and it would seem that this is
the only way uh for alireza to try and
make progress in this position for
example rook captures an f2 okay we pick
up the queen we give up the two rooks or
even uh we could throw in a queen to c
for chuck first just to be closer to
that d4 pawn and now after king to g1
now we can uh
uh capture on f2 for example rook
captures on f2 and now queen captures on
d4 we get this position where this pawn
will also be captured as it's really
impossible to defend it if you defend it
then queen g4 check picks up the rook so
it would be black would be better would
it be enough it's hard to say you know
all depends on how the the players would
pl would play it uh but instead firuja
goes queen to d7 and now we have rook
h2b3 now putting more pressure on the on
the b7 pawn and now again uh shoot all
it is a capture on f2 once again it's
possible it's a little bit different now
for example captures captures captures
and captures uh with check now we get
queen captures on d4 and it's a little
bit different because now for example
rook to f8 checking c7 rook f7 check it
goes after the b7 pawn right away king
c6 and now you can pick it up with
either rook and you get this position
but still
black black should be better again it's
hard to say would it be enough but it
would be a start but ferruja played b6
uh and that this just allows shiroff to
completely eliminate all of the threats
he just plays queen to c5 uh
rook captures on v6 is is an instant to
draw just in case you were wondering
captures capture so now after king day 8
we're going to play queen to c4
as you of course this is covered by the
black queen so we're going to play queen
to c4 uh and now uh for example rook
captures on f2 we go king to e1 and now
after rook to f1 check king d2 and now
we get a nice perpetual here because you
really do not want to go up the board
that would be that would be really bad
for white so we'd probably see some sort
of a perpetual here
sorry after uh rook to f1 king to e2 not
king to d2 obviously uh so yeah after b6
we have
queen to c5 and now preparing to put
more pressure here then the queen could
capture on b6 but now we have queen to
be seven violins and now rook captures
on b6 um
i'm grabbing that pawn
uh and now we have of course rook
captures on f2 yeah and instead of going
for this rook captures uh on v6 there's
really no way to make progress here if
you play something like d5 as soon as
black plays uh uh
king to a8 then you will no longer be
able to
exploit this it's uh you know just a
better position for black
even though it looks like you could be
doing something your queen is hanging
now and now after the queen moves you
can simply play queen captures on d5
doesn't really matter uh black would be
you know
up upon at least and you know enjoying a
better position so here rook captures on
b6 was played we have rook capture sun
f2 with check now king the e1
and now of course rook to f1 with check
king to e2 and now a nice repetition of
moves just rook f2 checking you want to
get one check into e2 and he was in this
position uh on move uh 42 uh that shiro
and uh furuja agreed to a draw as there
is nothing more to be done here so uh
you you could try uh you know to
escape but it really doesn't work for
example uh if uh now after this uh check
we go king king to d3 just rook to f3
and that's the game over king to c4
we're gonna play a captures on b6 and
now if uh rook captures on v6 it looks
very scary but it's not a rook the c2
with the check and it's white who's in
trouble king to b5 and now of course
rook to b to check and that's it for
example king to c4 rook captures on b6
now white is completely busted
uh so after the skin to move uh they
agreed to a draw and now it's a very
interesting situation at the top because
they were sharing first place before the
game uh and not all of the games have
finished but i think all the games that
are able to
you know have some something to say
about who's leading the tournament have
been played and now we have three people
in the lead after six runs and that's
still allergic uh maxima sherlock and
alexis shirov uh after this uh wonderful
wonderful game
uh so yeah really an awesome clash i
thought it was very exciting uh i i was
expecting the sicilian and you know
everything to just be flying but uh all
it is i thought that it'd be safer going
for for the car con maybe and then you
know trying to exploit this but in the
end it was uh shiro who who took a new
turn and well probably surprised alireza
a little bit
uh so a great game uh a very very uh
well impr
expected performance from alireza but
definitely impressive performance by
shirov who
for someone who with such an aggressive
style to you know to to be
uh uh so so dominating and leading in
such an event is always very very
pleasant to see uh but yeah that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
holy salt and i would like to thank
heather rose tom daralo lucas de ocaris
and james mayberry for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
event cheering up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday